welcome to this video playing alias and
he is going for d6 ok let's see what I
can do here the old Indian ok yeah let's
see me can also transpose to a kings in
you know of course but he stays within
within the old Indian Territory and ok
c6 yeah I normally play Bishop e3 here
I've got got a message ok he went nite
c5 hi I can actually try to win a pawn
but I don't think that's any good right
Bishop c5 95 now that's not looking good
so we have this and this is a position
that I of course like why it has a nice
setup the ideal setup so to say with
tonight on d to where it might jump to
see form at a later stage and black
hacen does not have any em on quick I
want to play he's just going back ok so
let's gain some spatium a4 a5 is a good
idea and asking him where he wants to
put his pieces ok so night age 7 and
Bishop g5 is an idea that he seems to go
for so I better pressure d6 a little bit
okay so what are you doing here then FY
is going to take white so let's
stabilize this and threaten 95 can I be
five now really curious what he's doing
now a seven is hanging be six there's a5
a6 there's bishop be 60 Knight b6 both
looks quite terrible okay so a five I
always have an intermediate move here
yeah like a six Bishop takes b6 okay so
he's attacking here for real so what am
I going to do here a b6 still or queen
bee three maybe just queen bee three ok
let's in fact a pretty decent defensive
move it seems I cannot really not take
on b6 I would like to from a technical
point of view but it doesn't seem to
work night a seven as a move maybe okay
let's let's keep keep it simple here
right f4 I might just take it's a
debatable move but I might just take
because i have a takes be six hour
afterwards
I cannot really do something else e 2 is
hanging and rukia one is a is lousy so
I'm going to take it here I have 94 c 6
as ideas i wonder if i should take on
not i can i'm going to take and now 94
496 the only drawback of this operation
was of course that he 5c 5 and the long
diagonal yeah but I really think that
the knight on c6 should compensate for
quite a lot it possibly Bishop b5 this
is also quite nice and also getting the
pawn right how does he keep the b6 pawn
Quincy seven root a seven cannot be the
solution it's actually still using the
Queen right well let's in fact quite
funny if I play rook here now Eric a
seven I'm threatening Bishop a six
trapping the Queen how does he prevent
that his Queen has no squares absolutely
no squares how does it prevent dead
hitter he doesn't react to the idea so
Bishop a six-night c5 probably yes
bishop is this assisted hauling hard to
believe right i mean i can take b6 of
course let sets do that and then think
about it is there any way bishop see 893
there is no wind er right membership t7
is almost trapping the rook almost ok
and I can take him
yeah and now I have to really trade
stuff right if I check on is if i click
on a six with the Queen oh I will take
me to at the end huh I am better than
but not winning especially playing rook
a 60 k 6 still Bishop e2
here okay
yeah yes to take a6 l what is the point
of thinking okay I was thinking I should
just trade ropes maybe and try to play
for for this end game but he cannot do
very much I can't play f5 rook a 72 d
soundness also i move I should have just
trade I don't know I'm k a bit concerned
about the f5 counterclaim ok I'm going
to trade rooks looks a bit strange to
trade my active rope here maybe time
morning but this is mostly also because
of the time I want to simplify stuff
now I have mice my pawns on light square
so his Bishop has a hard time attacking
anything and I'm trying to put a push
the King up and trying to do something
against his dark squared pawns
he's investing some time now don't
really see what is once to do maybe he
ok he was concerned about possible
trades i guess going this was going to
there ok we can he can push the King can
move the king of but i don't think that
leads to much mmm i won't know can i
really just okay we're going to see what
you what is up what is up Jim I want to
go all the way to the seven and then and
then and then a tech g6 should be
towards quite strange my ideas king up
to this home and trying to attack the
pawns from behind ya know there's also
possibly e5 okay maybe his idea is
simply that mmm dalits in fact
interesting okay i can't check into the
snow right push this stuff promoting up
unless i'm overlooking something very
simple check
check
check yeah the the night is stopping at
the porn and my own pawns are pushing
and promoting check just not just no
stay away please laughter I have to have
to double check that was that was not
easy at all it looked like I should be
about winning around here but somehow it
didn't materialize what exactly did I do
wrong with this this and now how do I
win this Bishop b5 this also looks very
strong but Bishop a 6 is not not really
decisive yeah okay the computers very
differently viewing this night a 590 5 b
76 seconds I dia maybe yeah the end game
that we had I think was probably not
much at all it is probably coalition but
what it was it was very safe and he did
not ever do something against my plan
you just let me execute this to
perfection and I was promoting it say of
course with this limited time it's a
it's tricky okay I'm glad to have gotten
this winning hope you enjoyed it thanks
for watching